in the mummy I was told there was going
to be a kissing scene between you and
Tom Cruise and then something went awry
I mean it was a very sad day for Annabel
I had there was this again another
amorous moment a little kissing scene
and I got to certain I was like this is
an amazing moment I'm gonna tell all my
friends my children about this kissing
scene with Tom Cruise and I get there
and we had 900 crew and I arrived on set
I'm like come on Tom it's about to be
the best day of your life and then he
goes yeah about that Alex can we have a
chat I'm not feeling that I'm not
feeling the kissing scene and he talked
himself out of kissing me in front of
900 people he's in front of people and
he said I'm not in front of you can you
imagine what I felt like yeah not good
I'd have been right there for you
ridiculous that's madness out of if you
and I were in any kind of play at all
I would demand a kissing scene I
wouldn't and if there was one written in
I wouldn't I say oh I'm not feeling it
today yeah
that's absurd I mean I despise him now
really done
you